a farmer grows
531 tomatoes and is able to sell
176 of them in three days so is able to
sell
176 of them in three days given that his
supply of tomatoes decreases by 176
how many tomatoes does he have remaining
at the end of three days
so he starts with
531 tomatoes 500 let me give myself a
little bit more space to work with
he starts with 531 tomatoes and he's
able to sell
176. so he's essentially going to
subtract the 176 that he's selling if we
want to figure out how many he's left
with so we're going to subtract 176
that's how many he sells in three days
and they're asking us how much does he
have left at the end of three days so we
just have to subtract those 176 from the
amount that he grew so it turns into
this straight up subtraction problem so
let's see if we can
do it
so if we go straight to the ones place
right over here and actually let me do
it in parallel because i think that
might be interesting over here i'm going
to do it the way you traditionally do it
here on the left and then i'm going to
show you what's happening over here on
the right so 531 is the same thing as
500 plus 30
plus 1. and if you subtract 176 that's
the same thing as subtracting 100
subtracting another 70 and subtracting
another six and i wrote it this way
because the 5 and
531 is the same thing as 500. the 3 in
531 it's in the tens place so it's
really representing 30. the one in 531
is in the ones place so it represents
one
and now it'll be a little bit clearer
what we're doing when we're borrowing or
regrouping on this problem right over
here
and so let's start off with the ones
place one is less than six one is less
than six be great if we can regroup some
of the value from the rest of the places
so we could go straight to the tens
place the tens place we can borrow or
regroup ten from it so if we take ten
from here this becomes 20. we're going
to take that 10 and add it to the one
so this will become 11. we just added 10
we moved over we moved over 10 from the
tens place to the ones place if you look
at it over here you could say look we're
taking 10 from the 30 that becomes a 20
and then the 1 becomes an 11. the way
when i was first in school people would
say you would borrow one from the 3 and
you'd kind of just stick that one right
over here but what you're really doing
is you're taking a 10 from a 30 and
making it into a 20 and then you're
getting and you're adding that 10 to the
1 and getting 11. but either way you'll
end up with 11 in the ones place and now
you can subtract 11 minus six is five
eleven minus six is five now we go over
to the tens place
in the tens place we now have two minus
seven which is really representing
twenty minus seven twenty minus 7 well
we that's 70 is bigger than 20 so we
want to add some more to the tens place
well we could go to the hundreds place
to kind of find some more value to
regroup so let's see if we can do that
we have 500 here what happens if we take
100 from that
so we're just left with 400 here and we
take that hundred and we put it in the
tens place so instead of
instead of 20 we now have 120.
if you look at it on this problem since
we're using the places here we're going
to take we're going to take 100 from the
500 and have 400 and then we're going to
take that 100 that we took and put it in
the tenths place well 100 is 10 tens so
we're going to add 10 to this so this is
going to become a 12. once again the way
kind of the more mechanical or rote way
of thinking about it is that oh you took
one away from the four and you stick
that one onto the front of the two but
you're really taking 100 from the 500
100 from the 500 to make it 400 and then
adding that 100 to the 20 here and
making it 120. but you write it here as
a 12 because it's 12 tens you're in the
tens place let me write it down this is
the ones place
this is the tens place
and this is the hundreds place
so now that our
now that our number on top in the tens
place is bigger than a number on the
bottom we can subtract so we get 120
minus 70 that is 50 or 12 minus 7 is 5
but that 5 is in the tens place so it's
really representing 50. let me circle it
with the same color so you recognize
that this 5 is representing 50. then
finally we're in the hundreds place
finally we're in the hundreds place 400
minus 100 is 300
4 minus 1 is 3 but this 3 represents 300
this 5 represents 50 this 5 represents
5. and so we're done we get 355 the
farmer is left with
355 tomatoes at the end of 3 days or 300
plus 50 plus 5 tomatoes